hi I am so that Shiva pie from science
mission today we have a dr. Kelly
McNerney professor in medical genetics
at the biomedical research center where
his work focuses on stem cell behavior
innate immune responses inflammatory
disease cancer biology and therapeutics
in 2015 he also served as a scientific
director of the Center for drug research
and development the National Center for
Excellence aimed at translating
early-stage scientific discoveries into
therapies
he has garnered several awards including
the 2004 Chevelle Pfizer junior faculty
award from the American Association of
immunology Kelly Felice leadership role
in Canadian stem cell network center of
excellence and is the associate director
of Canadian allergen Network center of
excellence and co-director of his
biomarkers and bio informatics platform
welcome dr. mcnac knee to science
hangout thank you so can you talk about
yourself your background your education
your some of the previous work we have
done
sure an undergraduate degree in biology
and biotechnology from an engineering
school it's their polytechnic institute
and then i went to graduate school in
Birmingham Alabama with a my post my
graduate advisor was max Cooper at b
tselem enologist very very famous and
popular I worked on b cell development
there and then shortly thereafter went
to Heidelberg Germany to do a
postdoctoral fellowship at the European
molecular biology labs with a homeless
graph was a well-known person in
transcription factors that guide him out
of poetic cell differentiation and then
there I was working on cell fate and how
to
control differentiation of hematopoietic
stem cells and worked on a family of
proteins called the cd34 family I then
took that work and and started my own
lab at the University of British
Columbia in Vancouver at the biomedical
research center and that's really what
I've been working on ever since okay so
did me about do a lab that people sure
so yeah we have a medium-sized lab we
have two postdoctoral fellows four
graduate students and then always have
at least two or three undergraduates
working in the lab as well the lab is
fairly diverse most work on cellular
immunology but also a bit of cancer work
and some work in allergy I would say if
you want to just um everything up I mean
it would be we develop animal models for
human disease and then looking mutations
that influence the outcome of those
diseases and try to figure out therapies
that would be benefit to people okay and
you know the research is always ups and
downs so how do you motivate your
students to always up and running and
not to lose their cool sometimes that
can be challenging every student is
different than you you have to figure
out what makes them tick and what
motivates them my general approach is
actually to let them have a lot of
Liberty in guiding their projects so I
usually start out students and say okay
try these two or three projects see how
it goes
we've put paired them with a more senior
person in a lab for the first few months
so that they can kind of get the
skillsets they need and then as quickly
as possible I let them start to solo and
work on their own and I do that not to
leave them blank and by themselves but
more because I find when they get to
work on their own they get to develop
their own projects they work much harder
than if I come in every day and say
today you will do this experiment then
you will tell me the result and tomorrow
you
do that experiment if I do that then it
becomes my project knock there's and I
find that they're much more motivated if
it's their own project and they get
excited run into my office and tell me a
results so that's that's the general
approach and I always try to give them a
very safe project one that's that will
easily get them a publication and then a
very unsafe project which is more
challenging but if it works
we'll give them a will revolutionize the
way we think about a certain disease
aspect so I make sure that they don't
fall but I also give them the
opportunity to fly okay it's a good
approach and we say and talk to me about
your philosophy of mentoring like how do
you mentor the people and how you have
been mentored also yeah so um I think
I've always been mentored as a colleague
rather than a student and I think as a
graduate student really what you're
doing is you're learning to take control
of your own education you're learning to
become the perpetual student who trains
themselves and so what I try to do is
very quickly teach students to behave as
a colleague to come with me with
questions to brainstorm to share ideas
and we each correct each other when we
have misinformation or false ideas and I
find that if you use that approach they
become very mature very quickly and they
become very good at at guiding their own
development and I really think that's
the goal at a graduate student level is
to really train you to become an
independent investigator so I provide
them with the resources and the
opportunity and the rest is up to them
okay that's good and let's talk a little
bit about other than research like tell
me about your hobbies what do you do
other than research during your free
time
oh so I I like playing guitar I have a
band of aged professors okay what we
lack in skill we make up for with
enthusiasm
we enjoy playing music the other a bunch
of old professors drummer bass guitarist
singer that's one thing we do I practice
karate as well so I've got a black belt
but I was 16 and so I continued that and
and my wife and I and my kids have a
small cottage on the island just off the
coast of Vancouver that whenever we can
reroute treat to and do gardening and
watch the wildlife so that those are the
things that keep me occupied outside of
the lab good so coming back to the lab
again what made you get into stem cell
what interested in to get into stem
cells and the cancer or what was your
inspiration to get into that kind of
subject yeah I was a curiosity and
serendipity actually so I mentioned it
through my PhD I worked on e cell
differentiation and had been working
with a lot of cell lines which taught us
about B cell differentiation that I
wanted to go further back in the in the
hierarchy and look at the earlier cells
the cells that contribute all that
differentiation and I was lucky enough
to link up with a postdoc advisor who
had developed a new system for culturing
clones of stem cells that were
temperature sensitive and you could just
by shifting the temperature of these
cells inactivate the genes that had
frozen them and then why the
differentiation take place in a wave in
vitro and I found that fascinating and
that got me into looking more and more
at normal cells and how they
differentiate during development so
that's where things started as I
mentioned before we we clone this family
of markers of blood stem cells and
studying stem cells is difficult but
looking at gene knockouts for each one
of those family members of the genes we
started to get phenotypes in the variety
of different tissues and by following
our nose and tracking down how those
mutations influenced immune response
stem cell development we learned a lot
about the biology behind how stem cells
maintain this potency but that can
differentiated to a variety of different
issues that stop things started as luck
would have it one of those genes seem to
be really involved in the development of
cells involved in allergic responses and
anti-parasitic responses that's what got
us into chronic inflammation another one
of the genes was dramatically up
regulated in cancer and we started
studying its role in cancer and found
that it actually was involved in rapid
tumor progression and always marked the
most metastatic and lethal cancers and
so knowing that we developed antibodies
against that particular protein or
trying to use those to treat metastatic
disease now so okay just a matter of
following your nose and letting the the
science guide you where it will okay
yeah like from stem cells to cancer
inflammation everything so what are you
going to present today today I'll tell
you a little bit more about the chronic
inflammatory disease work okay so um we
began looking at allergic disease and I
was collaborating with someone who had
identified a new cell type in lung
called innate lymphoid cells these are a
newly discovered set of lymphocytes that
make all the same growth factors as
t-cells but they lack antigen specific
receptors so there are type of an eighth
cell that makes the same kind of
responses of t-cells and guides the
right allergic and inflammatory
responses and kind of an age-old
question has been you know when you make
a response to a parasite versus a
bacteria or a virus how does your immune
system know to do that how do they know
to make an adaptive response to that
particular pathogen if that's the first
time you've ever seen it and the answer
is these innate lymphoid cells are what
guide that so I'll tell you about a
transcription factor that we identified
that guides that response and I'll tell
you how studying that we've learned a
little bit about chronic inflammation
and disease okay so that's right do the
factors called row alpha and the way
this work began is
we first started looking at so I'm just
moving the slides forward for you I
first need you to share them
oh sorry how do we go about that just on
the left side there we go how does a
transcription factor called roar alpha
that said not expressed in the Nate
lymphoid cells and how that plays are
all an acute airway inflammation did you
share the screen whole screen because I
see all the background in the whole
screen we do one thing you can do is
just get out of it and come back
how's that okay now it is good excellent
yeah so first tell you a little bit
about how raw Ralph is involved in a
night lymphoid cell development and that
plays out in lung acute allergic disease
then I'll tell you about a different
role it plays in innate lymphoid cells
an intestinal fibrosis with chronic
inflammation and then finally a little
bit about how that gene also on God's
cell fate and differentiation mm-hmm so
the work starts with again this
collaborative reword he identified a
subset of cells and lung that looked a
lot like stem cells but found that they
made these T cell cytokines
that seemed to be involved in
inflammatory response it was a cell type
that didn't make any sense fire current
understanding of how cells differentiate
and make a long story short those are
innate lymphoid cells we gene profiled
them and found that those cells tend to
make a transcription factor called rora
alpha and that was only expressed in
these natural helper cells it was not
expressed than any other cell types we
found in lung now as luck would have it
there was a trip already a mouse that
had a mutation in that gene
that gene is called roar alpha stagger
my C's are called stagger mice because
they have some neurological defects that
make them walk unsteadily they have
developmental defects but if you look at
the blood system of those mice the one
thing they lack is these innate lymphoid
cells type 2 so what we began doing is
taking the bone marrow from those mice
and transplanting it into wild-type mice
and now we have a chimeric mouse which
has normal development nor neural normal
neurological function but selectively
lacks that trance that cells like the
native one cells type 2 and we took
those mice and analyze them for allergic
disease and here are three different
models we use for looking at allergic
disease in mice one is a house dust mite
model so house dust mite is an allergen
that 85% of people who have allergies
will be allergic to what we do if mice
is we spray that allergen into their
nose as a priming phase and we wait two
weeks and then we challenge them
intranasally with the same antigen and
they develop allergies just like people
so that's one model a second model we
use is an old albumin model this is a
different model where we take a chicken
egg white protein we inject that
intraperitoneal in the mice to make them
primed and then we challenge them again
intranasally and develop allergies
against that protein the difference
between these two models is one is the
natural route of priming through the
nose the souther one is intraperitoneal
it's a systemic priming and we wanted to
look at the role of these innate
lymphoid cells in these two different
models the third model is
hypersensitivity pneumonitis this is not
a th2 diseases of th17 driven lung
inflammation very different from asthma
but also along inflammatory disease and
the goal is to find out what these
innate lymphoid cells do in each one of
these models so
here's just a quick overview of what you
see if you make mice allergic to this
house dust mite wild-type mice you can
see in this section of lung have lots of
inflammatory infiltrates all along the
airways they get lots of inflammation
around the blood vessels they get
inflammation this is what allergy would
look like a human lung if you look at
the Rafah knockout mice the ones that
lack ILC twos you can see their lung
looks like it's in much better shape
they have much less inflammation none of
the inflammatory infiltrate sin the
small Airways and only a little bit of
inflammation in the larger Airways so it
looks like these ILC 2's are responsible
for driving inflammation and if you take
them away
you dampen inflammation this is just
looking at cell counts the cells that
migrate to the lung in response to that
allergen and if you look at the roar
alpha knockouts they have about a third
the amount of inflammation of wild-type
mice and the main thing they're lacking
is eosinophils these cells that drive
the inflammation and remodeling of lung
in addition I ge is an immunoglobulin
it's made in response to allergens and
you can see that that's way down in
these mice as well so not only they are
protected from inflammation they also
don't make antibodies against the
allergen and so they're really protected
from allergy these are some cytokines
that typically you find in the lung in
response to inflammation so interleukin
4 interleukin 5 always come up with
airway inflammation and allergic disease
aisle 17 as well and as you can see
those are all down on the knockout mice
so they're failing to make an adaptive
immune response to this allergen now
that tells us that those cells are
critical for making an allergic response
in response to intranasal priming and
challenge what happens if you do
systemic priming using that other model
the old albumin model now if you do that
you inject intraperitoneal e with the
antigen now you get exactly
the same allergic diseases you would get
in wild-type mice you get the same
amount of inflammation and alone and you
recover the IgE if you look at the
cytokines produced they recover the
Aisle five and we also find they recover
the aisle four and thirteen but they
lack aisle 17 is tank th17 cells Otacon
which is a different type of immune
response so what that tells us is that
the innate lymphoid cells are critical
for intranasal priming and challenge but
they're dispensable for allergies in
this other model so just as a quick
summary this is what we found in
response to allergens normally what
happens as you breathe in an allergen
most allergens are proteases they damage
the epithelia in the lung that causes
the release of alarm ins or signaling
molecules that tell you that there's an
inflammatory insult these innate
lymphoid cells type to produce aisle 5
and 13 which recruit in eosinophils and
dendritic cells the acidophiles
immediately start causing those
responses that you associate with
allergy the dendritic cells pick up that
antigen they take it to the draining
lymph node they prime T cells the T
cells and migrate back into the lung and
now you are permanently allergic in the
absence of these innate lymphoid cells
none of that happens eosinophils are not
recruited in the dendritic cells don't
migrate to the lung you don't stimulate
that response and then you're protected
from allergies so that told us that
those cells are critical for an acute
inflammatory response in priming
allergies we then wanted to look at
something different a chronic
inflammatory disease and in this case we
decided to look at tissue fibrosis and
that's important because I would argue
that all of us if we don't die from
cancer or infection will eventually die
from fibrotic disease as you age your
liver starts to lose its function your
kidney
start to lose function the normal tissue
is replaced with extracellular matrix
and your organs start to slowly fail
that happens with age it also in happens
if you get chronic inflammation of the
tissues so we wanted to see if these
innate lymphoid cells play any role in
perpetuation of fibrotic disease and we
switch now to not looking at lung but
looking at at a gut model and we use the
Salmonella driven model of inflammation
so the model looks like this we take
mice and we first treat them with a bit
of streptomycin that clears out some of
the normal bacteria in the gut and then
a day later we give them a very mild
strain of Salmonella that causes chronic
inflammation in the guidance and this is
an attenuated strain as a vaccine grade
of salmonella it doesn't kill the mice
but it does induce a wave of
inflammation over the next three weeks
that mice clear that infection but then
what you see is deposition of matrix and
fibrosis of the gut and just to show you
what that looks like if you look on the
top panel you'll see what the gut of the
mouse looks like normally this is nice
epithelial layers and they got nice
submucosa and muscle here's what happens
21 days after you infect them with
Salmonella so you get this huge
inflammation in the gut and you see lots
of extracellular matrix dep is deposited
throughout all layers that they got this
actually looks like the kind of matrix
you get deposited in a patient with
crohn's disease a disease that causes
tissue fibrosis in the gut there's no
treatment for it really the only
treatment is to surgically remove the
section of God that has the fibrosis and
hope it goes away
unfortunately most patients with Crohn's
disease it doesn't go away so this is a
great model of Crohn's disease so we ran
every mouse pain we have in my lab
through this model including the world
alpha knockout mice and looked at
inflammation now if you look at the raw
alpha knockouts the first thing you
notice if you look
come or the slaying of the colon you
have equal numbers of Salmonella in all
of those tissues so the mice have equal
responses to the Salmonella where that
whether they have those innate lymphoid
cells in roar alpha or not but then if
you look at the matrix deposition on the
fibrosis it's night and day so wild-type
mice over time you see some matrix
deposition at day 7 at day 21 and at day
35 if you look at the Rafah knockouts
you get some matrix deposition at day 7
but then it starts to stop and a date 21
they look much better than the wild-type
mice and by day 35 its nine-day they
really have virtually no matrix
deposition compared to wild-type so that
tells us that in the absence of these
innate lymphoid cells you get more
matrix you you're protected from
fibrosis of the god this just shows it
in a prettier picture this red stain is
collagen staining in the gut these are
wild-type mice lots of matrix deposition
in fibrosis and the roar alpha knockouts
very very little if you look at
inflammatory markers those are all way
down in the Ralf a knockout so they make
less tgf-beta unless collagen 1a
interestingly enough if you look at the
th2 cytokines you see actually they're
the same in these mouse strains so
although there is a little bit less th2
cytokine where alpha knockouts these
levels are actually lower than they are
in the uninfected mice we went on to
look at Jacinta fils and whether they're
driving the fibrosis in this model and
the answer is actually no they're not so
these double gotta my slack all
eosinophils you can see that they get
the same amount of inflammation as
wild-type mice to make sure that this
wasn't a th 2 driven disease we actually
looked at stat 6 knockout mice and you
can see that they getting stat 6 is
downstream of alt h2 cytokine signaling
if you knock out stat 6 you're
completely protected from tht disease
but you see in these mines we get
exactly the same level of fibrosis so
roar alpha is playing a role but it's
not working through th2 cytokines so we
looked further at more cytokines in
these mice we found that aisle 6 was way
down the TNF was way down aisle 22 and
aisle 17 or way down in these mice these
are th 17 cytokines and they are also
expressed in innate lymphoid cells type
3 IOC threes so trying to put all this
data together and figure out what was
going on and why these mites were
protected we learned something new about
roar alpha so there are two
transcription factors one is called mer
alpha m 1 is called roar gamma they're
very closely related roar gamma is
expressed in th17 cells and IL TV threes
roar alpha is expressed in those cells
plus IL c twos we already knew that if
you take away roar alpha you lose all IL
c twos but the IL c 3 is in the active
17 cells are still there but what we
didn't know is whether those cells are
still functional in these knockout mice
and that's what we analyzed next as it
turns out if you look at the ILC threes
even though the cells are there in these
mice they fail to make this th17
cytokine aisle 17 same is true from the
t-cells they failed to make aisle 17
so yes the cells are there but they're
dysfunctional so if that's true and if
aisle 17 is what's really driving the
fibrosis so the gut we thought that
maybe if we used an antibody dial 17 we
could dampen fibrosis and that's indeed
the case here we show you what happens
if you take those seminal and infected
mice and treat them with a control
antibody and here's what happens if you
treat them with an antibody dial 17 you
can see the inflammation is way
down the matrix deposition is way down
and the gun epithelia looks quite good
so I'll see threes and I'll 17 or what's
driving the fibrosis in this Crohn's
disease model and if you manage to treat
patients with crohn's disease with anti
l 17 you probably be able to help them
and prevent that fibrosis as I mentioned
aisle 22 was also lower in those
knockout mines so we tried to look at
and see where their aisle 22 depletion
would make them do better
turns out that doesn't help them at all
it actually makes them much worse so I
think if you were to treat patients with
Crohn's disease with anti L 17 but then
also give them recombinant aisle 22 you
might be able to help them with their
disease and prevent fibrosis of the gun
so a quick summary of what I've shown
you is that in this chronic fibrosis
model Salmonella drives intestinal
fibrosis looks for all the world like
Crohn's disease the R or alpha knockout
mice are protected from that fibrosis
I've also shown you that the aya the
Aurora alpha knockouts failed to make
aisle 17 this th17 cytokine it seems to
be the major driver of fibrosis in this
Crohn's disease model what I didn't show
you is that it seems to be selectively
produced by the ILC 3s and finally
really the take-home message is that if
you had a way of inhibiting Rohrer alpha
function you could probably dampen
fibrosis and chronic inflammation in
those patients with crohn's disease so I
think that's a pretty good summary of
just one aspect of the work we work on
this a little bit of the chronic
inflammation we're looking at a whole
bunch of other fibrotic diseases like
muscular dystrophy that's a actually a
fine product disease we're looking at
kidney fibrosis which leads to kidney
failure in patients with diabetic
nephropathy and a variety of other
kidney diseases we're trying to sort out
whether these innate lymphoid cells are
playing role
tissue remodeling and tissue repair and
I think I can stop there and be happy to
take any questions or tell you about
other projects we have ongoing in the
lab okay if you can just go to the same
share and share it that would be good
double click on the share oh here we go
there we go thank you very much it was
pretty good so like I have a couple of
questions on this please one of them is
like there is lot of it's an excellent
work so I don't have to really question
your work per se but some of the things
like I've been seeing recently lot of
work implicating microbiome in all these
inflammation and all those things so
have you looked into in your model
anything related because I've seen in
initially you have injected some
antibiotics and all to get rid of some
of the micro biome and odd yeah so have
you looked in those terms it's a great
question and I'm absolutely sure that
the microbiome does play a role in
chronic inflammation in the gut we also
did a lot of the very early work showing
that the microbiome in newborns plays a
huge role in whether you're going to
develop allergic disease or not we found
that if you treat mice with very low
dose antibiotics you can make them
incredibly susceptible to developing
allergies later and that also fits with
a lot of clinical data kids who below
the age of two get multiple doses of
antibiotics are much more likely to
develop allergies and that's definitely
driven by the microbiome and we have a
lot of insight into how that gets how
that develops turns out that some of the
bacteria that first colonized or got as
an infant produce short chain
fatty-acids butyric acid particular and
that's a metabolite that your body can't
produce it has to be produced by the
bacteria
that if you don't have those bacteria
that make butyric acid you become skewed
towards being th too prone to prone to
allergic disease food allergies and
airway allergies and we've actually even
shown that if you did have
antibiotic treatment and provide butyric
acid and transy put in the drinking
water you can protect my strong
allergies so all that work suggests that
what the bacteria get colonized with
early in life can really have a dramatic
result influence on what type of
inflammation you get as an adult it's a
fascinating work and you have worked on
can settle and that is link between
cancer and inflammation so how would you
connect to your work with the cancer
whatever you have done with sure so as I
mentioned we were working on this family
of stem cell proteins called the cd34
family and all of our work says that
those proteins make cells more mobile
and invasive and help cells migrate to
the sites of inflammation but also
development cancer is a mobile and
invasive disease and it turns out that
tumor cells have stolen that mechanism
in order to be able to migrate and move
to different sites within the body so
the protein the cd34 family member we
work on there is called portal
collection that protein gets up
regulated on cancer as they transition
from primary tumors to becoming more
metastatic to it interesting enough
those proteins have a whole variety of
sugar of groups attached to them and
that glycosylated of sugar attachments
are actually different in cancer than
they are in normal cells so our approach
has been to make antibodies to that
tumor specific form of portal collects
them we develop some really nice
antibodies and those tend to block camps
of progression and mouse models very
effectively and we can take human cells
put them in my snake form aggressive
disease we inject those antibodies to
potent clicks and you can actually
prevent
after season 2 - we're trying to develop
that as a therapy No
so it's interesting you have done a lot
of work on different like connect
interconnecting this feels which gives
you a fuller story depending on where
you want to look at which will also give
you opportunity to dabble in two
different things simultaneously it's
been great you know I we find that
science is so complex and you know it's
good to have hypotheses and the first
time you do an experiment that you find
90 percent of the time your hypothesis
was incorrect and actually you discover
something much more interesting and the
thing you were looking for and it just
by being open and following the where
the leads take you you can learn a lot
about diseases and you need to keep you
a nice open always exactly I think it
was pastor who says you know opportunity
faves favors the prepared mind mine yep
so again dr. McNally thank you very much
I really appreciate your time so you
will I'll send you the link once it is
uploaded on the site so it should happen
within the next 24 hours or so so you
can use it to put in your website or
anywhere you want to and your this
should be there on our website and we
will post it on the Facebook Linkedin
everywhere so hope you don't mind
sharing your email address I guess so
people might want to contact you learn
about it or like I want to collaborate
with you or whatever like you want to my
pleasure so again thank you so much and
have a nice week like you use